hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar aldosterone and renin
measurements in the management of
patient and hypertension i'm susie
valdez of labrutz and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by dia
soren to learn more visit them at
diasoren.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our presenter dr paulo molotero
a full professor of internal medicine at
turn university dr milotero welcome you
may now begin your presentation sir
i'm paulo mulatero i am full professor
of internal medicine at the university
of torino i work in a division of
internal medicine and hypertension
in this
first seminar we will discuss the
application of the aldosterone raining
ratio in the management of patients with
hypertension in particular for the
detection and management of primary
aldosteronism the second part will
address the use of the aldosterone and
raining measurement to address the
therapy of patients with hypertension
and also to evaluate the adherence to
the therapy
we will begin with the traditional
application uh in the management of
patients with primary aldosteronism
european society of hypertension and
european society of cardiology
guidelines
of 2018 finally recognized that primary
aldosteronism is a frequent cause of
secondary hypertension
and
the landsat commission in 2016
identified the lack or delay diagnosis
of primary aldosteronism or in general
of secondary hypertension is one of the
key factors that
are associated in with
low blood pressure control around the
world
in the
talk of today i will use the
last consensus of the european society
of hypertension publishing the autumn
2020 for diagnosis and management of
patients with primary aldosteronism
we begin with the prevalence of this
condition
the two largest studies prospective
studies of this condition that were
performed respectively in the primary
care patient
that were seen by general practitioner
and in patients referred to
a potential referral center display a
prevalence of around five percent in
primary care and around 11 percent in
patient referred to specialized center
these data were confirmed also in other
population different from caucasian for
example in this study
from chonching in china we can see that
the prevalence of newly detected
patients with hypertension was around
four to seven percent confirming the the
data of five percent in our italian
population
despite this
evidence of a large prevalence of this
condition
a general practitioner in italy and in
germany
very rarely
screen patient for primary aldo you can
see that when
hypertension is diagnosed only three to
four percent of the patient
have an aldosterone reigning ratio
measured by their doctors
and so it's not surprising that the
detection of this condition is
so poor in europe
but americans do even worse you can see
that one only 1.6
of patients with resistant hypertension
are currently screened for primarily we
know this population should be always
screened by their doctors and the other
patient only in 0.2 percent and you can
see that this uh attitude is not
changing in the last 20 years despite so
many publication on this field show the
high prevalence of this condition
and we also know that primary
aldosteronism is associated to an
increased rate of organ damage and
cardio and cerebrovascular events
and this is due to the fact that
aldosterone
play an a role in the cardiovascular
system that is at least in part
independent from the effect on blood
pressure level inducing fibrosis
inflammation endothelium dysfunction and
many other effects that in turn are
responsible for an increased rate of
of cardiovascular event
in this meta-analysis we showed that
patients with primary aldo are more
prone to develop stroke coronary artery
disease
atrial fibrillation and heart failure
compared with patients with essential
hypertension and this is observed
even when a patient with essential
hypertension are matched for blood
pressure values with patients with
primary aldo indicating that the excess
for example of stroke is due to the
specific effect of aldosterone on on the
vessel and not due to an increase in
blood pressure level
of course if we have an increased risk
rate of cardiovascular event we also
have an increased rate of hypertension
mediated organ damage we can see for
left ventricular hypertrophy and
microalbuminuria
but
which patient should be screened for
this condition all hypertensive patient
ideally it would be
desirable but
probably for a con contention of the
cost we cannot ask this to be done we
can see the
[Music]
population of hypertensive patients that
are suggested to be screened by the
consensus of the european society of
hypertension in particular patients with
hypertension grade 2 3 or resistant
patients with an incidental
patient with spontaneous or diuretic
induced hypokalemia patient with a
suspected
familial form
and patient with atrial fibrillation
not determined by a heart disease such
as
for example a valvular dysfunction
we underline the importance of
in the patient with hypokalemia because
we can see that when hypokalemia is
present together with hypertension the
prevalence of primary aldosteronism is
almost 30 percent it is more and more
important when uh the potassium is lower
you can see here that when potassium
levels are below three mil equivalent
per liter the prevalence of primary aldo
is between 70 and 100 percent so we
should screen absolutely all of this
patient
but we should not forget that in most
cases at presentation patient with
primary aldosteronism are normocalemic
only one out of four of these patients
are hypokalemic
and presentations so we should not
request hypokalemia in all of our
hypertensive patient
we said grade 2 3 or resistant
hypertension this is because the
prevalence of primary aldo increased
progressively with the increase of blood
pressure level reaching 15 to 20 percent
in patients with resistant hypertension
atrial fibrillation is a new indication
in the consensus that was not
um introduced in the
endocrine society guidelines and this is
due to this study in which
primary aldo
was highly prevalent in a population of
patients with hypertension and
atrofibrillation but without an
underlying
cardiac
structural alteration
in contrast with the endocrine society
guidelines the population of patients
with the obstructive sleep apnea was not
considered at high risk for primary
aldosteronism in our recent consensus
and this is due to this large study
performed in europe
and
in asia in which we observed a high
prevalence of primary aldosteronism both
in caucasian and in chinese
patient however in most cases the
patient with primary aldo and ostracism
sleep apnea would have already another
indication for screening either high
blood pressure level or hypokalemia and
so on so only one patient would have
been missed with the current indication
of the consensus so we don't think that
obstructive sleep apnea per se is a a
condition sufficient to indicate the
screening in all of this patient
so which test we should perform
everybody accept that the best test is
the measurement of the aldosterone and
reigning ratio
and this should be
performed and measured in all the
patients we suggested
in the in the consensus
and we should choose a cutoff
for positivity that is different from
the cutoff that is suggested by the
endocrine society guideline they
probably refer to old studies
several recent studies show that the
best performance of the
screening test is with a cutoff between
1 and 2.7 for example here in the renato
study we observed the highest
sensitivity
in this
range of
arr values
therefore if we
want to compare the old
cutoff with radium unisa for example 30
when aldosterone is measuring nanogram
per dl the new cutoff should be around
two
with direct reigning concentration
of course the aldosterone raining ratio
should be measured uh without
interfering
anti-hypertensive therapy because we
know that uh most of
the
anti-hypertensive drug could determine
an alteration of the aldosterone rainy
ratio
ideally we should
perform the the measurement without
therapy before beginning the therapy but
in most cases this is not possible and
so the best drug that we should use are
uh aldous um
alpha one blocker for example doxazosi
calcium channel blocker such as
amlodipine or lercanedipine or even not
dehydropyridine like varapamil
thiazim another possible drug is
moxonating
however we could also
read and understand
the aldosterone ratio under interference
for example ace inhibitor and herbs
because we know that
this drug could potentially cause some
false negative diagnosis so a false a
positive diagnosis under this drug is
highly uh significant
or for example a negative diagnosis
enter beta blocker that can cause a
false positive diagnosis could be
considered a definitive
negative diagnosis the only two class of
drug that should never be taken are
mineral corticoid receptor antagonist
and diuretic both thiazide and loop
diuretic
after a positive
aldosterone ratio screening test a
confirmatory exclusion test should be
performed in most cases
in particular we can avoid
the
confirmation test if aldosterone value
are very high there there's hypokalemia
and raining level are
below the
detection limit so in this patient with
a phenotype that is particularly floored
we could skip the confirmatory test in
all the other we should perform a
confirmatory test because we would like
to avoid invasive subtyping procedure in
patients with false positive arr
the confirmatory exclusion test accepted
by the endocrine society and the
european consensus are four however in
europe we usually
use the intravenous selling load
performing seated position or the
captopril challenge test
the fluorine f test is already almost
abandoned
whereas in
usa for example
the oral saline load the test is
widely diffused
in this chinese study
it was shown that the best cutoff for
the capital test
is 11 nanogram per dl of aldosterone
instead of a percentage reduction of
aldosterone level and the ideal cutoff
for the saline load test is 8 nanogram
per dl
and in this study performed by the
brisbane group from of michael stewasser
we can see that they compare the
performance
of
the aldosterone measure in lcm sms
compared with the aldosterone measure by
chemi luminescent method and you can see
that the highest
specificity is obtained with a catophone
7.8 nanogram per dl and the highest
sensitivity with 7.2
it is important to underline that when
we perform this type of test we should
accept
a gray zone because we cannot
think that everything could be black or
white but
for many patients
in in the gray zone we should consider
the possibility of a very mild form or
the possibility of low reigning
essential hypertension
let's move now to subtype diagnosis
after the confirmation of the primary
aldosteronism subtype diagnosis should
be
should comprise
always a ct scan
with contrast
and very thin cut followed by
adrenal vein sampling in patients that
are candidates for surgery that is
patient that
consider
surgery at potential therapy so they are
open to this
to the surgical intervention
and they don't have major
contraindication to adrenal surgery
subtype diagnosis is fundamental because
we have to divide patients in those that
should be treated with
surgery from patient that should be
treated with
mineralocorticoid receptor antagonist
however there's a small subgroup of
patient that could skip adrenal vein
sampling if this is not
available
and go directly to surgery these are
very young patients less than 35 years
old with aldosterone level very high
more than 30 and
a
specific feature on the
adrenal ct scan that is a nodule on one
side larger than 10 millimeters and
normal adrenal gland in the
contralateral side
all the other should undergo to adrenal
event sampling that
is
relegated to very
specialized center and comprise the
cannulation of both adrenal vein and the
measurement of
aldosterone and cortisol in all the
sample cortisol in is necessary to
correct for potential errol in the
dilution when the blood is taken from
the adrenal vein
abs adrenal vein sampling is necessary
because in 38 percent of the cases
the imaging technique is misleading
compared with the final diagnosis so in
38 percent of the cases the diagnosis is
different from what is was suggested by
the ct scanning
we can have patients that lose the
possibility
of having the cure by surgery because
they have a bilateral lesion on ct scan
and the abs this show that the disease
is only in one side
we could have patients that are
inappropriately
operated
because of a unilateral lesion whereas
the
condition is bilateral or in a small
percentage of the cases we can have the
operation in the wrong side for adrenal
vein sampling we use different indices
both to
demonstrate the correct cannulation of
the adrenal vein and also to show
that aldosterone secretion is unilateral
or bilateral i won't go into detail
because this is a highly specialized
evaluation
when we have the final diagnosis uh we
should either treat patients with
mineralocorticoid receptor antagonist or
perform adrenalectomy when adrenalectomy
is performed
the
aldosterone
and raining level should be
measured to demonstrate the biochemical
cure of the condition we can see that
the clinical
outcome could be variable
because we can have patients that are
cured
patients that are improved and a small
percentage of patients that do not have
a variation of high blood pressure
possibly because there's two condition
in this patient responsible for high
blood pressure level that is primary
aldosteronism and essential hypertension
however the biochemical cure should be
obtained in most if not all patient and
should be demonstrated by normalization
of the aldosterone radiation
if we
look at the outcome after adrenalectomy
the patients that have the best
performance are patients young with
young age and patients with
low duration shorter duration of
hypertension
this
underlined the importance of the early
detection of primary aldo early
screening of this patient before they
became resistant to
drug therapy
for the therapy of the patient with
bilateral disease
we say that which they should be treated
with mineralocorticoid receptor
antagonist
and we should measure
aldosterone and reigning in particular
in the follow-up because you can see
that patient
operated
display a lower
rate of
cardiovascular and cerebrovascular event
compared with patients with essential
hypertension patients treated medically
could be divided into two group
one group with a
very
bad outcome considerably worse than
patients with essential hypertension
these are patients in which ringing
level are still suppressed
this indicates that the amount of
mineralocorticoid the receptor
antagonist that are taken by the patient
is not sufficient to block all the
aldosterone effect or the patient is not
completely adherent
by contrast there's another group of
medically treated patients in which the
outcome is similar to
the outcome of essential hypertension
and this is because
the reigning level are no longer
suppressed indicating a correct
mri therapy in summary in the first part
of this seminar we discussed the
application of the aldosterone reigning
ratio for the diagnosis and management
of primary aldosteronism in particular
we observe that the detection of primary
aldosteronism is still disappointing
around the world
and most patients with hypertension
should be screened using the measurement
of these two hormones to detect or rule
out
a condition that is it has been
demonstrated to be frequent
in
all population with hypertension in the
second part of the seminar we will
discuss about new application of the
aldosterone and raining measurement in
particular to address
to the ideal therapy patient with
essential hypertension and also to
evaluate the adherence of our patient to
anti-hypertensive therapy
the use of
reigning measurement in patient with
hypertension could help the clinician to
classify a patient
according to other condition
of responsible for high blood pressure
level for example patients with high
renin level
could have rhinovascular hypertension
theochromocytoma or the very rare renoma
patient with
low
renin level and low aldosterone level
could have
a genetic condition such as lidl
syndrome or 11 beta hydroxylase or 17
hydroxylase deficiency
so the measurement or raining could help
us in classifying the patient according
to under the underlying condition
john laraga many years ago used raining
level to classify patients with
hypertension according to three group
low raining normal raining and high
raining level and use
this
feature to
address the ideal therapy to this
patient in fact when we got a patient
with essential hypertension we are in a
difficult condition to choose among so
many anti-hypertensive drug
and we don't know which is the
preferable for a single patient and we
know that only around 50 percent of the
patient respond to the first drug that
is given to them
and so john lara
divided the
potential
therapy according to
in two group
v
drag and r drag v is for volume r for
resistance so for example
v drag are diuretics and calcium channel
blockers and our drug are beta blockers
as inhibitors and arbs
so when we measure rainy level if the
patient has
low renin level we should give a v drug
that is ccb or diuretics
if the rainy level are normal normal or
high we should give an anti-r drug so
for example s inhibitor or arms if the
patient is
on target we stop if the patient is
still hypertensive we can measure again
rainy level and take a decision
according to the new detected reigning
values
and this
hypothesis has been applied to many
relatively small studies we can see that
here for example rainy level where the
best predictor of blood pressure
response to anti-hypertensive drug
also
the running approach was considerably
better compared to the age and raise
approach of the nice guideline or to the
suggestion of giving diuretics to
everybody as suggested by the jnc 7.
in this small study for example the
running approach performed in terms of
blood pressure reduction reduction
significantly better than the
reduction of blood pressure obtained
with the suggestion of a hypertension
specialist
but this were a small study they were
not
too much accepted by the scientific
community and
poorly applied by clinician however the
pathway to trial clearly demonstrated
the
that john laragne was right
for example you can see here that when
patients are treated with
losartan
if
raining levels are low the blood
pressure response is poor when raining
is high blood pressure respond is much
better and the opposite is for thiazide
diuretic so we can use raining to choose
between arbs and diuretic for example to
hypothesize a higher blood pressure
response
in the second part of the study they
also
gave spinal actin you can see that the
response to spironolactone was
completely different according to
rainy level and according to the arr
patients with low raining and high arr
response responded much much better to
therapy with spironolactone
this showed clearly that not all
patients
are treated successfully with any type
of drug so we we can choose
according to rainy level or according to
the aldosterone reneration
another potential application is
impatient that
we consider candidate for renal
denervation this is a very invasive
procedure that using a radio frequency
and ablate and destroy the nerve the
afferent sympathetic
nerve into the adren into the
renal artery
we know that not all
patients with hypertension respond
at the same
level to this
invasive procedure
it has been published this year that a
patient with low raining you can see
here
below
0.65 nanogram per ml per hour
respond very poorly to renal denervation
by contrast patient with normal or
higher raining display a much higher
blood pressure response and if we divide
the
patient with low raining
into patient with very low raining you
can see that there's absolutely no
response on the procedure so we should
perform a raining measurement before
sending the patient to such an invasive
procedure
another potential indication of the
aldosterone and raining measurement is
to evaluate the adherence of the patient
to the anti-hypertensive therapy we know
that patient
of
suffering from different conditions
displaying the rest that is around 50
percent and this
adherence doesn't change according to
the type of drug that is administered
we know that is a little bit better in
secondary prevention because the patient
already suffer for a cardio
cerebrovascular event inhypertension is
around 40 percent because it's a
condition that gives no symptom in most
of the cases
and this low adherence is responsible
for
25 percent of hospital access in the
elderly so is a very important health
problem
you can see here that
when a therapy is suggested to a patient
uh there are since the beginning there's
some patient that do not take the
therapy and during the time less and
less patient are adherent and after one
year around half of the patient are no
longer treated
you can see here in these meta-analysis
that
incomplete or
complete not adherence
is present in at least 50 percent of the
patient and also in this trial in
patient candidate to renal generation so
they should be patient highly motivated
to take the drug
50 percent
of the drug
were not observed in the urine of this
patient by therapeutic drug monitoring
non-adherence is associated with an
increased rate of mortality
and cardio and cerebral vascular event
so is a very important
task to be improving our patient
so we decided to study if aldosterone
and raining measurement could be used to
evaluate the adherence of our patient
with hypertension to arbs or ace
inhibitors
we measured the aldosterone and raining
ratio in basal condition and after two
to eight weeks
after the administration of arps or ace
inhibitor we also measure aldosterone
raining ratio in a group of
normal volunteers to evaluate the
variation of these two parameters over
the time
and you can see that
after
two to eight weeks aldosterone level
went down raining level went up
whereas in normal volunteers the
two hormones
displayed a very small variation so we
could define uh a cut-off and we just
find it is around 50 percent that could
identify patient there were no adherence
so if after treatment the reduction of
the aldosterone raining ratio was less
than 50 percent the patient was
suspected to be non-adherent
to the therapy in that case we would
suggest the measurement of the drug in
plasma serum or urine urine to
demonstrate the non-adherence of this
patient
another
potential use is
impatient taking mineralocorticoid
receptor antagonist
this is the case for patients with
resistant hypertension or patient with
primary aldosteronism we saw before
in the other seminar that patient
treated medically should be monitored to
observe
that raining level should be not longer
be suppressed
during the therapy
if raining levels remain very low this
indicate that either the therapy is not
sufficient or the patient is not taking
the drug you can see here that after
administration of a carnot a
mineralocorticoid receptor antagonist
both in the short term
two weeks
and
in the long term
the aldosterone ratio was massively
reduced raining level increased whereas
aldosterone levels remain more or less
unchanged
so we can use
this measurement
not only a diagnosis of our patient to
rule out primary aldosteronism or
diagnose primarily dysteronism to decide
which therapy is ideal for each for
these patients so to understand
which is the preferable drug
to choose for the treatment and also to
evaluate adherence that is responsible
for
such a low
success in the treatment of our patient
in this second part of the seminar we
discussed about new application of the
aldosterone running measurement
this hormone could be
used to address the ideal therapy of our
patient with essential hypertension and
also to evaluate their adherence to drug
therapy
thank you dr molotero for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in from our
audience
our first question
when you use all the run-in ratio to
follow up on treatment do you take blood
while patient is on the drug
okay this is an important point and
because when a patient with primary
aldosteronism is treated with
mineralocorticoid receptor antagonist we
want to be sure that
we block every
receptor
and so aldosterone is not doing any
damage to our cardiovascular system and
to see that raining should not be
suppressed anymore and so the uh running
levels should be
unsuppressed
higher than 15 for example
and we we should measure uh rainin
under treatment because we want to check
the effect of the treatment on uh renin
and aldosterone
thank you so much now dr montero why
should i measure epr if only five
percent of the patients could have a
benefit
okay this is a frequent question uh that
a
clinician asked to me
first
hypertension is such a diffuse condition
that even just five percent of the
people is a an incredible number of uh
patients
second hypertension is a chronic
condition so
if you are
a hypertensive patient 40 or 45 years
old you
will have
at least 30 or 40 years of treatment and
if you got a condition that is not
essential hypertension you will be
treated by a drug that is not good for
you so you will have a much lower
success in controlling
blood pressure level and even you miss
the possibility of being cured by
adrenalectomy if you've got a unilateral
form of primary aldosteronism
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in our next question how can i
interpret epr in a patient under
interfering therapy if i feel it is
dangerous to withdraw from those drugs
okay this is a difficult question
because uh we know that most
drugs
could determine
changes in aldosterone and rainy levels
so we should
try to have some experience and
we can interpret the data uh even under
anti-hypertensive therapy first of all
if it's possible we we should
change the
therapy into uh drugs that are uh
known uh to have less effect on
aldosterone already measurement for
instance
alpha
blocker or calcium channel blocker
if this is not possible because the
patient is under beta blocker or ac
inhibitor so on
we can take into the account effect of
this drug so for example if we screen
our patient under beta blocker
and the alducino running ratio is
negative is normal so we can be sure the
patient cannot have primary
aldosteronism because beta blocker are
known to cause
some cases of false positive diagnosis
if by contrast
we have a positive ratio
so suspect primary aldo under acinimator
or arms we are reinforced in our
uh suspicion because uh a ace inhibitor
and arbs could give some cases of false
negative diagnosis so if the the test is
positive we we can really think the
patient can have primary aldo so we we
we could take into the account the
result and uh
and interpret the aldosterone radial
ratio according with the effect we know
the drug have on the aldosterone and
reigning
ratio the only
drug that is really interfering and not
allowing us to interpret the ratio is
paranal spironolactone and all the other
in some way we can manage
thank you so much
our next question from our audience
what position should the patient have
during the sample should they be lying
or sitting or standing and for how long
[Music]
okay this
again is a good question and this has
been addressed by the
guideline the endocrine society
guideline and the um
consensus of the european society of
hypertension uh in the old time we
measured
the aldosterone reigning
both under recumbent and
standing position and then so many
interpretations could be
done with this measurement
um
in reality now we make things much
easier so the patient can move from home
going to the to the lab
and so he's going to be standing for at
least one hour i think
from when you get up
and then the patient can sit just a few
minutes and the blood can be taken in
sitting position
is not so
strict that
is one minute five minutes or ten
minutes
guidelines say five minutes but if the
blood is taken after two minutes it is
not a big deal so
we we need to make guideline and
suggestion easy because
this procedure should be performed in
most of patients with hypertension so we
cannot ask
that the procedure is too uh
this is too complicated otherwise people
are will will be the reluctant to ask
for the test
thank you so much dr monotero we have
one more question coming in from our
audience
arr should be measured again after a
negative screening true or not true
okay and this is again an important
question um we can have
different situation you measure in your
patient the aldosterone
ratio and is negative but
borderline so
you can think the patient could have a
very very early stage of primarily in
that case you should measure again maybe
after one year six months two years
something like that
at least after one year you should
measure again
another situation is your uh aldosterone
regulation is frankly
negative
the patient is treated with for example
one drug or a two drug at low dose as
suggested by the guidelines
and the patient is okay is com is
controlled after five or six years
without any significant change in
his lifestyle for example is not getting
obese he didn't become diabetic or he
didn't
change the diet and so on the patient
became uncontrolled so something could
have happened
and
a second disease could
be superimposed to the first
diagnosis of essential hypertension so
maybe
primary aldosterone is developed in this
patient and so you have to measure
aldosterone raining ratio again
dr milotera thank you so much for your
time and your presentation today would
you like to provide any final comments
for our audience before we go
thank you for the opportunity uh i think
that we have to face the fact that
hypertension be such a diffuse disease
we cannot accept uh that is treated just
empirically in uh 99.9
of the cases we should rule out
secondary form of hypertension because
this treatment is completely different
from this patient
a patient that is
cured by adrenalectomy you change his
life because you avoid
this person take drugs for another 30
years with side effect with problem with
control
and
and so on or if it's
someone that should be medically treated
you give the right drug for this patient
we are in a in the in the in the years
of prestigious medicine and we we we
accept for hypertension we give always
the same drug to everybody this is not
acceptable anymore and not only
clinicians but also patient should ask
the diagnosis to be done before the
treatment is started
dr military i want to thank you again
for your time
and for your research we'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor dia
soren for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
laboratory alert you via email when it's
available for reply we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
bye bye